i think you might be jealous of course
i'm jealous i was never hiding that
okay if freddie's still in town benny
decontee will know about it he owns the
restaurant they all eat at he knows
everything about everything good hey
when you were undercover did you like
have a mafia best friend much else i'm
just wondering i don't know i guess i
did a bunch of jobs with a guy named
derek
great
great
derrick sounds like a great guy charles
don't do this to yourself all right okay
fine all right so we're going to the
restaurant what's my cover me and the
mob ooh i've got the perfect thing
the sun hat
no just be yourself a cop benny might
think i'm a rat so i'll go in and talk
to him then you come in a minute later
with your badge out pick a fight with me
and punch me in the face no i could
never hurt you jake well you got to hit
me somewhere i'm fine it'll be the ball
saying no just hit me in the face look
if it's so hard imagine i'm somebody you
hate derek i barely know him fine
just get it down all right don't shoot
that's how people get shot just shut up
shut up nypd drop your weapon
all right bianca what do you know about
a guy named derek charles no if he does
leave his room my new partner will warn
me new partner k-13
it's a robot i can program it to wait
outside holt's door and if there's any
movement it'll send us an alert all
right i'm in but only because your robot
is so cool i don't know it's not that
cool i mean all he's doing is standing
guard i mean i could do that awesome if
you do that then k-13 can come to the
party i am programmed to boogie my butt
no i'm going to the party people prefer
me over a robot
right this is such a surprise i haven't
seen you since i transferred here how's
amy she's great we're married and she's
a sergeant now wow yeah how's everything
here well samo samo guess who's here
herman herman always playing yahtzee
knew everybody's name worship satan did
he he never mentioned that
[Laughter]
you wouldn't shut up about it it is
exhausting
well i'm charles i'm jake's best friend
charles he's serving three life
sentences no need to flex so caleb these
guys are the worst hey stevie shillings
jakey p and the place to be what are you
doing here i thought you were in the one
two four i was man but then i arrested
all the bad guys instead and so i
transferred to the nine eight so dope
everyone put on your parkas cause this
week just got a whole lot more chill
out
allow me to introduce stevie chillin
shillins he was my very first partner in
one of the all-time greats takes one to
no one man come on
i'm charles
wha oh hey what's up man i'm stevie we
heard stevie and i were beat cops
together we called ourselves the beatsie
boys and yeah it was as cool as it
sounds
so y'all would just stand around like
that all the time totally get it my
first partner was also pretty cool
everyone called us chucky and the coot
so i guess we all had great partners
that we've completely moved on from
because yours died of old age he did
anyway we should motor jake and i are
sticking out a bar called the thirsty ox
loud crime a lot of danger a lot of down
time for inside jokes would you like
some milk
man would you like some milk the kind
because you look like your dog just milk
please what's it from it's fun he
remembers it's funny okay very funny
oh god it's my new partner you guys are
texting each other now it sends alerts
but what was that loud crash i think
that might have been me see you in l
partner
you killed her her oh my god it was a
her
you're replacing amy not me what have i
done wait the robot has a camera maybe
she saw who took the laptop there's the
laptop bag you think you're so much
better than me
you're right it's gonna fast forward oh
hey robot i got something really cool to
show you on the balcony i think you're
really gonna like it
oh oh you're heavy fast forward did you
guys see that he put the bag down behind
the plant let's go
swerve
yeah we say noice not swert look i'm so
sorry but i don't think there's room for
a third person on this case jake we
should work it solo well hang on now boy
let's not be hasty i mean stevie's been
tracking ozeroff longer than we have and
three heads are better than two he's a
crowd everybody knows that okay duke the
car's picking me and amy up in two
minutes you sure you're cool keeping
tabs on my cases while i'm on the cruise
you bet i hope you have a great time hey
don't make any new best friends
[Laughter]
uh maybe you shouldn't go hey charles
can we talk in the briefing room for a
second there's a question i got to ask
you hmm
it's happening
jake is gonna pop the question he's
gonna ask me to be his bm no bn best man
is a common abbreviation no one but you
has ever used it i am so relieved i
thought maybe he was gonna ask one of
amy's brothers or who sarge hey man come
on charles
okay
so i know this is a lot to ask no it's
not i want to do it you want to cover my
shift this weekend so i can go to the
white plains mall and meet daryl
strawberry at the opening of a cell
phone store
yes
that's exactly what i was hoping you'd
ask great thanks
you sure it's okay
i'm very happy about it that'll be fun
it'll be fun uh look at my smile i have
to go now
oh my god
jake what do you say bud will you be my
bm yes yes a million times yes
in your face terry what i'm holding a
sparkler for you i helped organize a lot
of this well you can stick that sparkle
up your butt i'm the best man
what are you doing come here
what
i think stevie's bad news what oh come
on charles you know you've been acting
weird about stevie all day i think he
might be jealous of course i'm jealous i
was never hiding that wow he's tall he's
funny he can pull off an earring he
doesn't have an earring but we both know
you'd look good in one oh my god what do
you want me to say boyle i've been
trying to include you in this all day
long and yes i forgot you that one time
but i made up for it i slapped you in
the face you're supposed to be my friend
i'm an adult man i can have two close
friends hell i could have three close
friends you wouldn't i would
maybe i'll get in touch with my friend
james from college ooh are you know who
just looked me up online brad from camp
stevie planted the drugs
come on i looked in that dishwasher
before him and it was empty steve you
planted those pills but you're right
he's the coolest you guys should go get
your ears pierced together invite brad
it'll be smirt
it's swert not smirt
so
joke's on you damn it stevie my second
year on the force i was working a drug
case tracking this drug dealer for
months then suddenly he disappeared
right before memorial day which i was
supposed to take off for a guys weekend
with some friends but how we didn't know
each other yet
oh
other friends
oh man three weeks is way too long
between visits i know i'm so sorry it's
been so hard to get down to south
carolina between work and spending every
free minute on your case all right
that's enough touching you used all the
touching time made me i get 100 of the
goodbye touching time 100
how they treating you are you safe yeah
i'm in protective custody because
everyone in gen pop hates cops i'm not
really sure why something about us
locking them in cages and letting the
world pass them by
so it sounds like you're isolated and
haven't had any chance to make new
friends oh my cellmate caleb is okay
just remember if he's in prison no
matter how small the crime people don't
change and don't deserve second chances
charles relax i'm not gonna replace you
trust me all i've been thinking about is
when you guys are gonna get down here
and now you are and we can finally talk
there's an incident in the yard we're
going in the lockdown inmates line up no
no no no no no i have 50 more minutes i
need this back to your sales right now
no
my touching time these fools don't stand
a chance against us yeah they really are
fools aren't they just like whoever
agnes and alfredo beat its singing to
get into the olympics i know nothing
about opera no you're right amy's a real
teresa braganza
look at them laughing
jake must have said something really
funny should we forfeit you hear what it
was no charles we're not forfeiting
you